Consciousness is truly an amazing phenomenon. Now think about it, you, as this
collection of atoms, obeying the laws of physics, can be aware. You're aware of
your mental activity, of your emotional state, even of your external
environment.
&gt;&gt; That's right. Have you ever been so involved in a task, such as writing a paper
or playing a game, that you've lost track of time? Or perhaps you've been
daydreaming at work when you should really be working. Or have you ever
wondered what happens when people take mind altering drugs? These are all
examples of questions related to the study of consciousness.
&gt;&gt; Now as you're going to see, consciousness can be measured on a continuum, from
fully conscious.
&gt;&gt; For example when you're awake and aware of your surroundings.
&gt;&gt; To not conscious at all.
&gt;&gt; For example if you were in a coma and unaware of your surroundings. In fact
Grey has a personal example that he's going to share with us.